Let's go next to our caller from the nine
one seven area code. Who is calling today
from nine one seven.
Is it high?
Yes, it is.
I believe so. Hi David. Uh, I liked your show,
your cool guy. I just have a quick question
about the, an opinion of yours on the impeachment
hearings. Do you find it concerning that the
focus of the public, uh, and media DOR slash
video seems to be on the political optics
rather than the fundamental shifts that are
governmental principles?
Yes, I do. So the way I've been trying to
say it is we can argue over the political
expediency of impeachment. We can argue over
the timing of impeachment. We can argue as
to what we think the outcome will be or whether
Republicans will grow a spine and vote. You
know, we can have all that conversation. Impeachment
is a process that is a duty of our elected
government. If the facts warrant it, and I
believe the facts warrant it and that is much
more black and white than all of these considerations
that are being made about timing, expediency,
probability for success. They're both legitimate
conversations. But I think the conversation
about the duty that exists is not getting
the attention it deserves.
Agreed. Very much. Agreed. A follow up question,
do you have any idea when, how the media uh,
could kind of like, cause to me as well, I
see this as pretty cut and dry it, it seems,
and it's apparent to me that there were definitely
misdemeanors that occur. I don't know what
the technical definition of high crimes. I
would probably tell us what he's done in there
as well as high primes, but like how could
the media hold those at fault because it's
not just him accountable while not sacrificing
therapeutic or retention. Because as we know,
Americans have a very short attention span
and I don't think we would be really interested
to listen to why it's bad
to listen to why, what? I'm not sure I understand
your question.
Alright. Um, okay. Let me try to rephrase
it. Do you think that there isn't a
a what? Hello. Okay. I didn't understand the
second question. The first one was a good
one and I'm glad that it was a point, a very,
very well made. Let's go next to our color
from the four four three area code. Who is
calling today from four four three.
Hello, David?
Yes.
Hi, this is Alex from Baltimore, Maryland.
How are you doing today?
Good. Thanks for calling in.
Can you hear me okay?
Can hear you fine.
All right, cool. Just making sure. I know
you get a lot of issues with that, so I was
just curious. When I talk politics with anybody,
I usually try to figure out when I figure
out which side, if they're left or right,
I try to find an issue where that they might
buck their own trends so to speak. That was
wondering if there's any issue no matter how
insignificant or minor that you see at least
at that. Do you see kind of from the right
wing perspective or are you all progressive
all the time no matter what?
No, listen, I mean there, there are overlaps
in the sense that for example, um, there are
left libertarian and right libertarian ideas
where there is probably more common ground
ideologically than some people might concede.
Although sometimes it's in the implementation
that there becomes more of a difference. So
I am against any regulation that is not a
necessary regulation to ensure the proper
functioning of society and industry. So like
that sounds libertarian. The, the problem
is I would drastically disagree with many
right libertarians about what the line is
for what's necessary. Right. I would want
way more regulation than they would, but at
least the concept I, I share a particularly
as like a social libertarian. I think that
on the issue of, let's see, I'm trying to
come up with a better example. Um, I agree
with the idea conceptually that if taxes go
too high, the economy will start to suffer.
But I would completely disagree with people
on the rightest aware that limits should be,
I think the top marginal tax rate should be
in the low seventies percent for income above,
somewhere in the range of five to $10 million.
So I agree. If you go too high a, then you
hurt the economy. The people on the right
agree with that. We just have a complete disagreement
about where that line should be said. So,
yeah, I mean, I dunno, I guess it, there,
there are some general areas where I agree
with a principal that might exist on the right
but would vehemently disagree about the implementation
of it.
Gotcha. That's interesting and nice to hear
your take. And, uh, I got, uh, another, uh,
minor complaint if you have a minute. Um,
I heard on one of your shows that uh, you
think a granny Smith apples are the only apples
that are worthwhile. I would have to say first
of all, how dare you. Um, uh, I'm, I'm just
kidding. Um, I would implore you to try a
pink lady and pour a summer R a summer Rambo
Apple if you've never had one of those.
I've never had a summer Rambo pink ladies.
Not bad. So I should amend my prior statements.
A granny Smith Apple is basically, so I will
disclose. I don't like Apple pie. I'm not
in the pie space and I particularly don't
like Apple pie. I don't care about pie period
unless it's like a sweet potato pie. Okay.
Granny Smith. Apple is the best Apple for
almost all functions. So if you just want
to have an Apple by itself, a nice tart granny
Smith is the best. If you want to slice it
up and put peanut butter on it, a granny Smith
Apple is the best. The exception is if you're
putting pieces of Apple in oatmeal and you're
cooking it with the oatmeal and the milk,
they're the granny Smith. Apple actually isn't
the best. And I would go with some version
of a red Apple in that case.
Yeah, I feel like I said I was just a good
break or your boss.
Yep. No, but it's a very, very serious issue.
I appreciate the phone call. Thank you so
much. I hope to hear from you again.